brought to you by thief visit amazon.com
/ thief contest to take part in the
thief mod competition and earn a chance
to win incredible prizes come on come on
I see you walking there I see you
walking he's mine haha
cam let's become expert thieves oh
definitely i'm sick of paying for stuff
are you dressed as a thief dude i am
i've got my ear defenders because if i
can't hear them they can't hear me say
oh that's very clever so I went with
with helmets sunglasses learn to protect
my identity it's a race I love races
alright first off go where we going no
no so you're gonna have to shoot man I
guess the zoo defenders are really good
we're racing racists go to burgle a
person okay then a store okay then
you've got to steal something with two
wheels right then four wheels okay
something knowing lies Oh something
their boats dead bird and then a final
challenge at the end you have to be
taking them from a person so you can't
steal a stationary car every one of your
items that you still you also have to
deposit in the safe oh the water
depository all the underwater bang who
wants to go in the water come on come on
I see you walk in there I see you
walking he's mine haha yes yes yeah this
is cop doing excuse me officer I don't
know what it is that you're doing but
i'll show my god officer but this guy is
going in you're going in the water sir
oh [ __ ] what if I if I deposit the cops
in the water I guess that counts okay oh
god oh god mr. blue people in using
grenades ok it yeah see see now you're
just stealing my idea go on yeah you're
right I did see your idea and it worked
perfectly god damn it do I get at least
partial credit for that get in the water
all the way backwards they went
backwards are now I'm on fire yeah I
never kill people it's all about
knocking the most there we go he is the
Nocturne are we not allowed to kill
people no not med 200 all right so
what's it what is it blackjack only I
think it's blackjack only okay not to
help nice okay oh yeah and he's on his
feet I'm gonna sneak my way in I've gone
with brazen thief he won't see
hello he doesn't see me he almost
certainly doesn't see me know but still
oh yes oh god I like jacked him that
money will be safe at the bottom of the
sea what oh god all right i tried the
whole deal bail out before deposit oh no
good job I definitely left the money on
the seat to it shine okay all right two
wheels where am I gonna find two wheels
excuse me sir have you seen any
two-wheeled vehicles but have you know
okay oh god I'm fire again it house here
how's your search going I'm not good sir
I've been trying to remove wheels from a
car and I've removed a lot for my car
but all four wheels remain yes yes find
one that was on a motorbike bodes well
for me to someone could really hurt
themselves in this is if they weren't
really properly trained and it's gonna
go hop you're just jump here whoa oh oh
no did you die oh yeah oh thank god big
wheelie into the water we're assuming
you're not big wheelie yeah easy
successfully stolen serve our God
successfully dismounted deposit my own
stall a night oh here I come watch out
let's not have a repeat of last time
four wheels four wheels dual wheels Oh
BAM I would never ever crash land on you
well nice good job are you swimming to
the seaside where are you swimming team
uh the ladder is a ladder haha before
you two three go just for you girl oh
let me just are you cutie what he
stepped on me I always get a knife you
in the gut there's anybody out there on
a boat no alright got my blackjack ready
all right I'm gonna need I'm gonna need
to get there get the law started one law
please oat missed your unconscious he's
still right up in the water yeah good
effort I'm gonna take a jet ski and then
use it as a tool semi deceive oh ho
hello these guys aren't a jet ski oh no
oh I am totally gonna leave this jeske
but I need to use my blackjack or not
the lahar knock them off like so [ __ ]
skiing couple gray I left a long way
away that was dumb all right it's fine
it's bare blow up mine's just [ __ ]
off ideal get it ah it's too bad oh I'm
gonna stand on your jet skis shoot my
jet ski now that doesn't kiss does that
doesn't count Bashir yes of course it
does I'm says long as I'm able to shoot
my own jet ski if I have to be on yours
oh oh you were in the way of my bullets
you son of a [ __ ] that's so unfortunate
that's so unfair no you were in the way
my bullets it's bear kill majeski as
well there were another just to be sure
your one's fine another grenade yours
hasn't sunk yet enjoy alright something
that flies I ran over some fools oh god
damn it your offense is meant to go down
I know this there you go you done no
such thing oh god I bounced right off
yes yo something to fly sab money in the
bank in the right place squash I've
already parked my plane down there are
you gonna deposit your helicopter yeah
amazing that was epic I'll keep that
there for later I find work fine work
all right although i will say said I did
win seeing okay I had to play in their
first I concede so on I'm sorry one but
why don't why don't we double down on
your own you can only be such a good
thief sure but if we combine our
thieving skills think what we could
steal think about it I mean we could we
could steal jets huh we could try to the
Jets straight to the Jets oh there are
there are loads of hitchhike quick
different route oh [ __ ] I got hit by the
tank Greg you can steal us a jet it's a
team I was a distraction rule number two
in thievery is a little bit shy of
distraction kick it go man go you've got
your flight gear on yeah straight up
awesome the quick gun it away from there
before you
get shot down oh jeez damn it oh no
welcome to the swamp Oh despair sad the
swamp we are terrible thieves we are we
are I'm sorry dreamt went for the big
prize the big score yeah and we failed
I'm gonna gas us to death okay oh but no
sab no i don't i just want breathe in be
fine don't don't breathe in you we come
on I just gonna hold if I do this then
I'll be fine yeah breathe through you
okay you can breathe it in sir but I i
invite you doing no breathing I doubt
okay I can hold on ready for hours hold
it I will uh-huh uh-huh Oh got up my
nose
you